Hello! Happy summer time, everyone! I want to paint this picture for you. Oh. Right now, I am in a fluffy sundress that doesn't hug any part of my body. Okay. Maybe I've lathered myself up in some sunscreen, put on a big floppy hat, and I'm hoping there's a glass of rosé in my hand. I believe that right now I will have on some blousy pants
with lots of pockets. Oh, yeah. I have just sprayed bug repellent all over my body, and hopefully I also have an adult beverage in my hand because we're on vacation! But we didn't want to leave you this week, so we thought we'd share an episode we loved. It's branch closing.
You remember this one? It's so good. So good. There's the brilliant Jim Prank with Future Dwight. Oh, yeah. And then Jan tells Michael the Scranton branch will be closing and everyone freaks out. There's also some big Jim Caron news. Oh, yeah. And most exciting, we got to talk with Chip Eston,
who played Josh Porter, who was the manager of the Stanford branch. He talks all about his time on the show, and he could not be more charming. So charming, and he had some great stories about scenes with Ed Helms. We also discussed my low pony in this episode, Angela. I know. We'll see you back here next week. With the surplus. Oh, and that's a good one, too.
That's a new one, guys. That's the one where you guys surprised me. That's your birthday episode, lady. I know. All right. We'll see you guys then. I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey.
We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week, we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hi, folks. Hello, everybody.
I'm sorry. I feel like I just shouted. I won't do that again. If you shouted, then what did I do? I don't know. I don't know. I'll pull back. We're a little amped up today, guys.
We're excited about this episode. We're amped up. We're excited about this episode. Also, seeing my BFF's face and Sam and Cody, like the four of us, is kind of just like one of the highlights of my week. Every week. It's one of the highlights of my week. Yeah.
It's true. It's The Office. This week's episode is Branch Closing. It is season three, episode seven, written by Mike Shore and directed by Tucker Gates. Yes. Tucker Gates directed four episodes, one of which people absolutely flip out over is the Threat Level Midnight. We'll get there.
Yes. Oh, yes. All right. Here's a summary for this episode, jumping right in. Jan tells Michael that the Dunder Mifflin Scranton Branch is shutting down. What? Michael, of course, shares this news with the rest of The Office, even though Jan told him not to.
I mean, what are you going to tell Michael something and expect him not to just blurt it out? He's like emotion-driven. The guy cannot hold anything in. No. He can hold nothing, basically. Yeah. So, everyone is wondering what their new life will be like.
They're talking about it. They're thinking about it. Meanwhile, Michael and Dwight drive to David Wallace's house in hopes of ambushing him and saving the branch. They're going to save us, guys. Even if they have to be aggressive, like, what they're going to show up at this guy's house? What are they thinking?
Yeah. Thank God he didn't come home. Well, we eventually learned that Josh from Stanford leveraged his position to get a new fit staples, and the Stanford branch will now be closing. The Scranton branch will absorb some of their employees, which means, guys, Jim is coming back. Oh, Jim is coming back. It's a big episode.
That's a lot of information we find out in this episode. So much information, and it sets up the rest of the season, really. It really does. Yeah. We're going to, and this is, we're going to get our new characters now. Malmes, Rashida Jones, Angela, we're finally next week going to be able to interact with those Stanford people. Yeah, and they really, they really get under people's skin.
It's so fun. All right, but we're getting ahead. We're getting ahead of ourselves. Jenna, now you and I were being chatty on the phone yesterday. Jenna, you were a little, I don't know, braggy to me on the phone yesterday. You said you had fantastic fast facts. You wouldn't tell me. So what do you got?
What do you got? You were a little braggy. I was a little braggy because I am actually really proud of these fast facts. The first one is a little soft. I'm going to just preface it now that we've built it up, but fast fact number one is that this episode of branch closing, it now streams as a super sized episode. It's longer than a regular episode. It runs about 30 minutes, but when it first aired, it was a regular episode.
This ran on NBC as a shorter episode, but immediately following the airing on television, NBC released what they called a producer's cut where they put back some deleted scenes. And that is the version that now streams today, this producer's cut. Lady, that's a very solid first fast fact. Oh, well, thank you so much. Yeah. That's really good. Thank you so much.
I forgot that. I forgot that. And when I watched it, I noticed it was longer. And I was like, we always had the big announcement about our super sized episodes. Remember? It was always usually at the end of the season. And I was like, how did this one get in there? That's how.
Okay. First of all, I think that this really speaks to how much stuff we used to cut from episodes. Because when you watch this episode, it feels awesome. You're like, oh yes. And it kind of shows all the things that we used to have to cut out. And as we go along, I'll point out some of the things that only got to stay in because of this added time. I'll mention the things that were cut for the network airing.
But I think this also speaks to a time historically when websites and the idea of web traffic or exclusive web content, it was just blowing up. This is the very first kind of exclusive web content of the office that NBC put out, this producer's cut. And it was because NBC wanted to drive traffic to their website. Yes, which is also why we did those webisodes. We started doing more and more content for NBC.com. I started doing a thing called Adventures with Angela where I would go around the set
and make these videos and they put it on NBC.com because they were really starting to see, hey, this internet thing is probably going to be the way to go. And this was still before social media. This was still before Instagram, Twitter was around, but it was very much just starting and it wasn't what it is today. But yeah, now you almost expect it. I feel like now you watch a television program and you're like, where's my extra content? Where's my behind the scenes?
Where's my extended cuts? But this was like just the very beginning and branch closing was part of that. I find that fascinating, Jenna. And also, yeah, you're right. This is a timestamp, right? If we're tracking old tech, our show started before there was streaming. Oh, Angela, Fast Fact number two is a major old tech tracking. You're going to love this.
What? All right. On January 9th, 2007, Apple introduced the first iPhone. I don't know if you remember this, but it was unveiled during a presentation by Steve Jobs. We got some mail from Aaron McDonald with what might be my favorite tip off ever. He said that the cold open from this episode was the first ever piece of video played on the iPhone and it was done during that presentation by Steve Jobs. Wow.
We were part of this global moment, like without even knowing it. It blew my mind. Here is something even more crazy. I watched the whole presentation. Also during the presentation, Steve Jobs, when he's showing you how the music stuff works, he plays the Green Day song, Boulevard of Broken Dreams. Angela, in season six of The Office, Dwight and Andy sing Boulevard of Broken Dreams in the Secret Santa episode.
What are you trying to tell me, Jenna? What is happening? Is this an episode of Lost? Is this an episode of Lost? Group Mind. Group Mind's Time Portal. What's happening? I don't know.
I think it's crazy that both a video of The Office and that Green Day song were both part of this presentation and then later that same Green Day song shows up on The Office. It's so many coincidences. What's happening? I think it's a collective of amazing creative minds. It's a group mind of great stuff. You've got an iPhone. You've got The Office.
You've got Green Day. It's Group Mind. I don't know. Okay. All right. What's next, Jenna? Fast fact number three. There are a ton of talking heads in this episode.
Did you notice? Well, yeah. Because everyone's reacting. I did notice that. Everyone's talking about, oh, what am I going to do now that the branch is closing? And then when we find out the branch is not closing, everybody talks about, oh, here's my reaction to that news. Do you remember when we talked about how our cinematographer Randall Einhorn chose the
placement of a talking head based on whether or not people had a future outside of Dunder Mifflin? Yes. To refresh everyone's memories, we learned that most characters have the office of Dunder Mifflin behind them, behind them in that window as they're giving their talking heads. And the reason behind this was that that meant people were stuck. They didn't really have a future. They were kind of stuck in the world of Dunder Mifflin.
Right. However, very often Jim would have a talking head all the time and his talking heads had a window to the world behind him. Yes. And the point of that was because he had a future outside of this company. Yes. Right. He was going places.
Yes. Angela, in this episode, after the employees get the news that Dunder Mifflin Scranton is closing, every single one of the talking heads have a window to the outside world behind them. No, they don't. Oh, yes, they do. What? Wait.
I just want to make out that the branch isn't closing, all of the talking heads switch back to having the bullpen behind them. I did not catch that. You have to watch it. I have to go back and watch it. Angela, you have a talking head where you're talking about Dunder Mifflin closing and outside world behind you. Same with Pam, same with Ryan, same with Phyllis, same with Stanley.
And then when we find out that we're still stuck at Dunder Mifflin, Dunder Mifflin is behind us. That is so wild because I really don't think I ever had talking heads on that wall. I mean, I'm trying to think back, I think maybe one time when I was sitting next to you when we were both pregnant, right? Yeah. You're like, wow, Jenna, that is a fantastic, fast fact. It's subtle, but it's layered and it's there.
Everybody watch branch closing again just for the talking head. That's it. That's what I got. I'm giving you some claps all around. Thanks, lady. I was really proud of that one because I tracked that one myself, so I'm giving myself a real pat on the back for that. I'm raising my glass to myself.
I don't know if you can see, I'm raising my coffee mug to myself. I'm raising mine back to you. You do, as you raise your coffee mug, I notice you have a tattoo on your wrist that you normally don't have. I was fascinated and fixated on it. Did your kids give you a sticky tattoo? You know, Angela, in this pandemic, we have brought back some real oldies, but goodies at our house, and one of them has been the temporary tattoos.
This is something my kids were interested in when they were like two or three years old, and they're now eight and six. We found this drawer of temporary tattoos and we're tattin' up. You know what? We found one as exciting as your tattoos. We found in the shed a bin of unopened Play-Doh, and it was still good. Our kids are 12, 12, and 10. They're not, you know, that's when you sort of phase out a Play-Doh, you brought it back.
There's a chicken that poops Play-Doh, it's made a comeback. Lady, those fast facts were so good. I mean, where do we go from there? We should probably take a break. Let's take a break and then we'll dive into this episode. It sounds great. All right, we're back, guys. We're going to start breaking down this episode of Branch Closing.
We're going to start with that cold open that we told you ran during the unveiling of the iPhone. Yeah, so this is a classic gym prank. He has found a way to prank Dwight even from the Stanford branch. He is sending a fax very early in the morning. Karen enters, she's a little curious, like, what are you doing? And he's like, it's too hard to explain. And we see a talking head where Jim says that he stole some of Dwight's stationary before
he left, and he occasionally sends Dwight a fax from Dwight's future self. It's so good. It's so perfect. It's so perfect. And that morning he said, don't drink the coffee. Might be poisoned, right? Something to that effect. It's like, oh my God, and he sees Stanley about to take a sip of coffee, and he practically
tackles him to the ground. He's like, you'll thank me later. So Dwight thinks he is getting faxes from his future self. This is classic gym. It's so good. It's so good. The first thing I thought after I watched this cold open was, did Mike sure write this episode?
He did, because that's Mike sure. This is 100% from the brain of Mike sure. He did such a good job of writing these Jim Dwight pranks. Oh, he's so smart, Jenna. He's so smart. I know. He's smarty. Yeah.
All right. So then we move into the episode, and Michael is at his desk. Jan enters. Oh, Michael, again, like three hellos. Just call me Levinson in the morning. In the morning, Levinsons. And you know, Jan has news to deliver, but first she has to sit through this barrage of awkward hellos from Michael, and she finally tells him, Dunder Mifflin Scranton is closing.
You are a severance package person. Yeah. You're not going to make it. Michael starts crying. And then he starts like moaning. Like how, Jenna, can you imagine like in this moment? No. And of course, it's so loud.
Everyone from outside the office can see and hear that something is going down in his office. Everyone's very curious. Yes, because he's like, like he's moaning. Kevin comes over to Pam's desk, wants to know what's going on. We had a fan question. Okay. I'm going to let this fan question go.
And then I have a card that just says, what? Is it what Hadley Horton is wondering? Why is Pam's hair different? What's up with the Lopony? Oh, that's a separate card called Lopony. And Mark, okay. Where should we start? Should we start with what or Lopony?
Let's start with what and then go into Lopony. Great. Pam calls Kevin Kev and then Buddy and they fist bump. What is happening? What is happening? Well, the fist bump was a reluctant fist bump though, Ange. I know. But Kev, Buddy, fist bump.
She's being condescending. She's being totally condescending. She's trying to put him off. She's like, Kev, Buddy, fist bump, leave my desk. I mean, she's trying to get through it. That's my interpretation. My interpretation was that he's like a little kid. Yeah.
Yeah. So she's patronizing him. Yeah. For sure. But you just don't often hear Pam sort of become that casual with Kevin or, you know, I feel like she saves that part of herself for Jim and everyone else. She's sort of just aloof to a little bit. So it just kind of was startling to me that in your Lopony tale.
I mean, what the heck? Here's the deal with the Lopony. I think it was a swing and a miss. I wasn't crazy about it when I saw it. We were trying to change things up. You might notice as well, Pam has got a little bit of like a pinkier, sparklier eye shadow on in this episode as well and a little lip gloss. There's so much pink.
There's pink eye shadow, pink lipstick, pink sweater. But then the Lopony with the clip, not even a ponytail holder. I can't wait. Wait. I sounded so southern. It's very hard for me. Holder. Anyway, it's a clip holding your hair, not even a ponytail holder.
Yeah. Well, the clip is humongous. Here's the thing. The conversation in hair and makeup was that Pam would be experimenting a little bit because she's going to her art classes. She's living on her own. We needed to see some physical representation of the fact that she's attempting even in small ways to break out of her shell right now, to break out of her routines.
So there you go. We offer the Lopony. I'm going to say I think you never see it again because it wasn't great. Can we just say it wasn't great? It's a clip Lopony. Yeah. A clip Lopony. Now I kind of wish they'd really gone for it.
Next week you would have had a banana clip. Remember those things? Oh, God. They gave you like a mohawk. Yeah. Yeah. All right. Well, it was a moment in time.
It was something we tried. Unfortunately, it's there for us all to see again and again. Okay. Don't say unfortunately to me. Do you see how many Loponies my character has? Like all the crazy hair- I don't have a problem with a Lopony. I don't have a problem with a Lopony in general.
I'm just saying this particular Lopony was because of the giant clip. It was odd. We're back in Michael's office and Jenna, I don't know if you've ever had to fire someone I have or if you've ever been fired, but I couldn't imagine getting the news Michael got and Jan's like, well, you know, they believe that Josh Porter is going to have a big role in the future of the company. And Michael goes, what kind of role? King of the stupid universe?
Yeah. Could you imagine like firing someone basically who's having this kind of a spiral? I mean, Could you imagine firing someone or being fired and then having their wind up mechanical teeth go off? Was that in the script? It was an accident. And by the way, this points to what amazing actors Steve and Malora are because they just
stayed in the moment and reacted to it as if that was meant to happen, it was not meant to happen. That's brilliant. And could it be more brilliant that you're firing this guy who's so incompetent on so many levels and his clacky teeth go off? Yes. Amazing. All right.
I'm going to move us along. Michael has a talking head where he says, let's see Josh find another Stanley, Phyllis or Kevin. Show me that farm. Show me that farm. And during that talking head, we kind of we see Creed eating his mung beans at his desk. We see Phyllis knitting and we had a fan question from Stephanie Miller. In this episode, when we see Phyllis knitting, can she knit in real life?
Did she knit that whole scarf her character is working on? You guys, she is 100% fake knitting Phyllis cannot knit. Didn't she do so good? They had a basket full of knitting stuff. They'd made it part of her character. It sat next to her desk all nine seasons. And it just sat there. And sometimes if she had to do background stuff, but this was a great panning shot because
Michael says there is no Stanley tree and he's napping. And then they said, do you think the world is crawling with Phyllis's and she's knitting? So it was this great visual, but no, Phyllis can't knit. Yeah. No. No, that's one of my favorite talking heads though. I love that one. I do too.
I do too. So then Michael is walking around the office. Dwight can tell something's wrong, but Michael isn't spilling. And this is my other favorite talking head from this episode, which is Dwight's talking head where he says, when you're close to someone, you can read them like a book. And he says, Michael's book is titled something weird is going on colon. What did Jan say, the Michael Scott story by Michael Scott with Dwight Shrut. All right.
That last part is not in the script. And I could kind of tell that there was an improv there because whenever rain improv's at the end of a talking head or the end of a scene, I feel like you can see him smile just a little bit in the corners of his mouth and his eyes. So I reached out to Mike sure and he told me that he and rain expanded on the book title on the day on set. They kept throwing out ideas. The original was just supposed to be something weird is going on colon.
What did Jan say and Mike throughout the Michael Scott story and then rain added with Dwight Shrut. Yeah, for sure. I mean, I feel like we all have tells and rain when he has an improv that I think he's really happy with has a little bit of a smirk. He's kind of proud of the moment. He amuses himself in the moment while saying it. Now things are really getting heightened over at the Stanford branch because Karen breaks
the news that the Scranton branch is closing to Jim and oh my God, Jim's face. He's like, what? You notice he doesn't reach out to Pam. Pam and Jim never call one another or text one another in this whole day. It's kind of weird because in Diwali, we see that Pam was texting Jim and they had that phone call at the end of grief counseling. But what's going on? Why no communication?
It makes perfect sense to me. They're both sort of struggling with where do we go from here and I'm sure Pam's first instinct is to reach out to him, but she doesn't feel like she has that kind of access to him anymore. She rejected him. So no, it makes perfect sense to me that they don't communicate. What I thought was weirder and we're going to get to it is that Roy finds out from accounting. So Pam didn't even tell Roy.
That's right. So now Michael approaches Pam at front reception. He's acting really strange. She clearly knows something is up because he was moaning in his office and Jan visited. So Pam's like, what's going on, Michael? Yeah, I have a fan catch from this moment. Okay. So at six minutes, 21 seconds, Celeste Dimas says, if you freeze and look closely on that
big board that's hanging by accounting, on Tuesday the fifth, it says, one of many Emmys, Steve was robbed. Oh, that's a great fan catch. I promise I didn't write it. We shot this episode about two weeks after the Emmys and I guess someone had written up on the board a little congratulations to us and we also needed to say that Steve was robbed because he did not win that year for Michael Scott. He never won for Michael Scott, which is ridiculous.
Yeah. Well, I have a Jenna catch because since Celeste turned me on to looking at this white board, I found something else on the white board on the top line written under Thursday, written in multiple colors. It says, in case you haven't noticed, there is a lot of colorful hooey on this board. Anyway, guys, for the future, I think it could be very fun to freeze on this white board because they did change what they wrote all the time. Well, I love that.
I love the little subtle shade towards the television academy about Steve not getting the Emmy. Totally. Coming up next, Michael has a talking head and then he does something immediately after and it's one of these classic Michael moments that I live for. It always makes me laugh so hard. Michael says that all he can do is put on a brave face and be our leader. And then he says to the whole bullpen, it's over.
We are screwed. Yeah. Like really, buddy, that's the brave face you're putting on for us. Okay. Thanks. Yeah. I mean, he really, he offers no comfort. He sort of begins to ugly cry, Angela is asking about the employees, asking about their
jobs. I have two catches here. I have something I need to say, Angela. Okay, go. At seven minutes, 18 seconds, your sweater. It's a sweater vest. Okay. So I actually have some photos of this sweater from a wardrobe fitting that I saved.
So I have a button down shirt and then over it, I have a sweater vest, but it's like a tank. It's like a teeny, tiny, very odd sweater vest. Yes. It's like another one of those failed project runway contests. Oh, 100%. And then our wardrobe designer, Carrie Bennett, took the buttons off the sweater vest and replaced them with those cat faces.
It's really a work of art. It really is. All right. Well, I have a catch at seven minutes, 27 seconds. This is one of the most famous Michael Scott memes. It's Steve making that face, like he's about to cry or maybe he smells dog poop. You know the face. And he says, this is the worst.
And people use it a ton to respond to other people. Like when they get some news that they're like, no way. All of a sudden, I see in my feed Steve's face. Okay. On Office Ladies Pod, will you please post the pictures of your cat buttons and of this meme? Yes. Of course.
Of course. Okay. Good. Because I want everyone to have these visuals. Okay. I think it's important. I have a script question, Jenna, because I know you have this, the scripts. So Toby admits that he knows that this was going to happen.
Michael calls him a traitor, says he wants to see him in his office. They start to walk in and Michael says, oh my God, you walk so slowly. I feel like that was Steve improvising. I had that same feeling. And I did look at the script. None of that part of him calling Toby into his office was scripted. So him, that whole bit of him calling Toby in his office, say he's walking slowly and then Dwight guarding the door and putting his hand up to the camera, none of that was
in the script. Amazing. Yeah. Amazing. And I love that everyone just went with it. They're just like, oh, Steve's doing his thing. We're going to let this play out and participate. Because I looked, I was like, wait, is there a lost scene of Toby in Michael's office?
Is there a conversation that didn't make it? No. No, that was just Steve on the day. Wow. And you know, speaking of how Rain gets the little smirk when he improvises at seven minutes, 52 seconds, when he won't let the camera crew in and he shuts the door, he has the smirk. I noticed it too.
Uh-huh. Well, we had a fan question from Mary Poulton and actually a lot of people wrote in with a similar question. She wanted to know, when we got the script for this episode, did any of us worry that the show was being canceled or did we know that this was just an idea for an episode? And she was asking, and a lot of people were asking because we've said before, sometimes plots are revealed to us at these table reads and they were shocking and they wanted to know as we sat down and got the script, as we were reading it, were we thinking, wait
a second, what? Scranton's closing. Are we all out of jobs? No, guys, we knew that this was a plot point. None of us were worried. We had all had our contracts renewed for all of season three. And so we knew that we would be producing 24 episodes in season three and we also had been tipped off to the fact that eventually there would be a merger episode and that those
people from Stanford would be coming to join us. So we didn't have any kind of surprise or anxiety when we got the script. No, we were just excited because it meant finally, after this episode, we could all be in one room together. So we were excited, at least the Scranton branch, we were excited. I don't know. Maybe Stanford was like, we like our schedule, but we were excited to have everyone back. All right, so now, Angela, we move into a Ryan talking head and he's holding up his
business cards, right? Are they his calling cards? Oh boy. Uh-huh. He's holding up his business slash calling cards. Eight minutes, notice, here it is, talking head exterior window behind him. Oh, nice. This is the beginning of the exterior window talking heads because next up, Angela has
a talking head and Kelly has a talking head with the mascara on her face, all exterior windows. She's going to track it. All right, so now we're going back to Stanford and Andy is leading everyone in a chance. Stanford Connecticut, right, he's getting everyone worked up. So while everyone's chanting at eight minutes, 23 seconds, you will see someone who is beloved by our office cast and crew. Her name is Lori Sox.
She was our stand in her and her husband, Steven, they were like a stand in duo team and she's in the background in the scene and it just made me so happy to see her. I saw her too. I saw her too and I loved it. Well, maybe we should explain what a stand in is if we haven't before. So after you rehearse a scene with the actors, you bring in people to stand in for the actors while the crew sets the lights and the camera angles. And this is an opportunity for the cast to go and get their makeup fixed or change their
outfit or any number of things, rehearse their lines. And then when we're ready to start rolling, the actors come back in and stand in their positions or sit at their desk. So Lori would stand in for all the women and Steven, her husband would stand in for the men. But every once in a while, you'll see them pop up in the background of scenes and that's what happened here. Yeah, they're wonderful and we all became very close and anyway, I was very excited
to see her there. I know they were the loveliest and they had two kids. Lori got pregnant twice over the course of the show. Everybody who worked on our show became part of the family and they were part of our family. Yes, absolutely. Well, back in Scranton, Meredith goes into Michael's office to let him know that she is still down to sleep together. She's still down to get down.
Yeah, because, you know, they made a pact years ago that they would sleep together on the last day of work and Michael is like, I have no idea what you're talking about. Okay, this storyline, which is going to keep playing out of Meredith trying to figure out who she agreed to have sex with on her last day of work. This was an example of one of the storylines that got cut from the original NBC airing. Oh, okay. So we were able to keep this storyline in because we got the extra time with the producer's cut.
Oh my gosh. And see, I love it. I feel like it fills out the picture. Yes, completely. Well, Jenna, your character has a pretty big talking head coming up. You know, it's interesting to see how the branch closing is affecting everyone. I mean, Stanley is elated, right? She's going to retire early.
Oh, yeah. Stanley is elated, Ryan says this worked out great, and Pam is really happy. Oh, yeah. And we express all of those emotions with an exterior window behind us, Angela. Well, Pam says that she always thought that maybe she would make a big speech and slap someone and storm out. So dramatic. I know.
Oh, yeah. Stanley is elated, ryans says this worked out great, and Pam is really happy. Oh, yeah. And we express all of those emotions with an exterior window behind us, Angela. Well, Pam says that she always thought that maybe she would make a big speech and slap someone and storm out. So dramatic. I know.
Who would she slap? It would have been me. She would have slapped me. Well, she's eventually going to slap Michael. So maybe that's who she means, but it's definitely either you or Michael. Right? Yeah. Yeah.
100%. Okay. So now, Angela, we're over in accounting, and Angela and Kevin break the news to Roy. Yeah. Why? Why do Angela and Kevin break the news, huh? Why hasn't Pam said anything? I don't know.
I think this really shows how disconnected Roy and Pam are, by the way. Well, he seems very concerned that Pam might be one of the Connecticut transfers, but Angela kind of misreads his concern and thinks that he's worrying about himself. And she's like, oh, Roy, you'll be fine. You're so strong and capable. Yeah. Don't worry, Roy. Yeah.
Don't worry, Roy. Kevin finds this hilarious. Angela tells him to grow up. Yeah. He totally storms off. We got a fan question from Patricia Kennedy. Patricia wants to know, Angela, when you're talking to Roy, it seems like Angela has a thing for Roy.
Did she? Patricia, this is a fantastic question. All right. Many of you out there have speculated about Angela and Roy. Jenna, I have been asked this question a lot, and there's all of these threads online about it. So the answer, Patricia, is yes. It seems like Angela always had a thing for Roy.
I love this question, Patricia, because this has given us an opportunity to track it. We're going to track this Angela Roy flirtation because it is real and it is happening. All right. Early on, there are a few episodes that kind of hint at this Roy-Angela flirtation. I believe it starts in the fire. This is season two. Remember when the members of the office are playing the game, Who Would You Do? And Michael asks Roy, Who Would You Do?
And Roy says, What's the name of that tight-ass Christian chick, the blonde? Yeah. Sort of referring to Angela, right? Yeah. And I'm standing right there, and I'm like, my name is Angela, and he's like, Hey, Angela. So definitely it starts there. And then in the secret, when Angela and Phyllis are in the kitchen and they're cleaning out the fridge, Phyllis asks Angela, Who'd she pick if she were in Pam's shoes, Jim or Roy?
And Angela's like, Oh, I don't want to participate in this, right? But then she gets this kind of weird look on her face, and she goes, Roy, weird look. It's like a confession. It's like, well, Roy. Yeah. But then this just keeps building, right? And it's further fleshed out in the first ever The Office webisodes, Jenna. So the webisodes were called The Books Don't Balance.
It featured the accounting department. And if you watch it, go to episode five titled Someone in the Warehouse. The accountants are wondering if maybe Roy took the missing money. Angela says absolutely not that he has too much character. And Kevin asks Angela if she has a crush on Roy, and Angela gets very, very flustered. Oh. Whoa. She gets so flustered, she like, she like sort of messes up her words and then she sort
of storms off. And you can find this on the DVD set, it's on season two, disc four as a bonus feature. But yeah. So that happens in the webisodes. Okay. Well, then in season two, Casino Night, there's a scene where Michael addresses the crowd in the casino, and he says, old friends, new lovers. And if you look in the background, Angela and Roy are sitting next to each other at
the bar. And you guys kind of exchange a look. I know. It's one of the things that's been pointed out on the message boards. What's the look between Angela and Roy at Casino Night when Michael says, new lovers? And why are they sitting next to each other? Right? Why are they?
I don't know. And then of course, in this episode, Branch Closing, we have the scene at 10 minutes, 33 seconds, where Angela, like we said, is trying to confront Roy, tells him he's strong and capable. Yes. And then also, if we skip forward to the Cocktails episode in season three, you will briefly hear audio of Roy asking everybody at the bar if they want to drink. And you can hear Angela say something like, oh, no, thank you, Roy.
我不知道。然后当然，在这集《分公司倒闭》中，在第10分33秒的那个场景里，安吉拉正如我们所说，试图去质问罗伊，告诉他他又强壮又有能力。是的。然后还有，如果我们快进到第三季的《鸡尾酒会》那一集，你会短暂地听到一段音频，是罗伊在酒吧里问每个人想不想喝酒。你能听到安吉拉说类似“哦，不用了，谢谢你，罗伊”这样的话。
And everybody thinks that maybe that's your character kind of coyly talking to Roy. Yeah. It's kind of odd that it's left in if you watch it, because it's off-camera. And I'm like, oh, no, Roy, I'm okay. And it just kind of trails off. So it's like, what is that about? And then my personal favorite in the episode, The Negotiation. This is also season three.
然后每个人都觉得，也许那是你的角色在含蓄地和罗伊说话。是的。如果你看的话，你会觉得把它保留下来有点奇怪，因为那是画外音。我就想：“哦，不用了，罗伊，我挺好的。”然后声音就渐渐变小了。所以就让人觉得，这到底是怎么回事？然后是我个人在这集《谈判》中最喜欢的片段。这也是第三季。
Roy is coming in to get his very last paycheck, and Angela keeps having everyone in the office retell her about the moment Roy tried to attack Jim and Dwight intervened. I mean, there's a scuffle, and she just keeps wanting to hear about the scuffle. And it seems like she's just as turned on by Dwight's, like, being a hero as by Roy sort of being this aggressive dude. Well, this is Angela the character's fascination with a sort of alpha male display of, I don't know what you would call it, just testosterone. She loves a big display of testosterone.
罗伊进来领他最后一份薪水，而安吉拉一直让办公室里的每个人向她复述罗伊试图袭击吉姆而德怀特出手干预的那一刻。我的意思是，有一场冲突，而她一直想听关于这场冲突的事。而且看起来，德怀特作为一个英雄的举动，和罗伊这种带有侵略性的男人的做派，对她来说同样具有吸引力。嗯，这就是安吉拉这个角色的迷恋之处，她迷恋某种阿尔法男性的展示，我不知道你该怎么称呼它，就是纯粹的雄性激素。她太喜欢这种宏大的雄性激素展示了。
Yes. Don't forget, she mentions that she has had two men have duels over her. Yes. She loves all of this. She loves all of it. Roy is 100% in her wheelhouse. Okay, so we've tracked it, but Angela, you went to Greg and to Paul, the writers, to get their intentions behind this whole thing.
是的。别忘了，她提到过曾有两名男子为她决斗。是的。她喜欢所有这些。她喜欢这一切。罗伊完全长在她的审美点上。好了，所以我们追踪到了这一点，但是安吉拉，你去找了格雷格和保罗这两位编剧，去了解他们安排这一切背后的意图。
What did they tell you? Okay, yes. I went to Paul because he wrote the webisodes, and it is so plainly spelled out that Angela has a thing for him in those. And I went to Greg as well, because I just felt like he had this overall view of everyone's relationships. This is what Paul said, we never really entertained it going anywhere. We just thought it was funny that Angela liked this rougher, less tolerant guy when the rest
他们对你说了什么？好吧，是的。我去找了保罗，因为网络短剧是他写的，里面非常明白地写着安吉拉对罗伊有好感。我也去找了格雷格，因为我总觉得他对所有人之间的关系有一个全局的看法。保罗是这么说的：我们从来没想过让这事有什么后续。我们只是觉得很好笑，当世界上其他所有人都觉得这家伙是个混蛋、大家都在支持吉姆的时候，安吉拉却偏偏喜欢这个更粗鲁、更难以忍受的家伙。
of the world was thinking, he's kind of a jerk, and they're all rooting for Jim. So they sort of liked that foil, right, that I was team Roy. And then this is what Greg said, Greg said, Roy and Pam were more of a traditional relationship and Pam needed a more modern, equal relationship, but it made sense that Angela would be attracted to Roy. They could have turned into something, but Roy had to get in line behind Dwight and Andy. Oh, I love it, oh, I love it. All right, so then Michael is down in the warehouse, he's talking to Daryl, he finds
所以他们有点喜欢那种反衬，对吧，就是我是罗伊阵营的。然后格雷格是这么说的，格雷格说，罗伊和帕姆是一段更传统的恋情，而帕姆需要一段更现代、更平等的恋情，但安吉拉会被罗伊吸引是合情合理的。他们本可以发展出点什么，但罗伊必须排在德怀特和安迪后面。哦，我太喜欢了，哦，我太喜欢了。好吧，然后迈克尔下到库房，他在跟达里尔说话，他发现
out that Bob Vance has bought the warehouse, and Michael really starts to spin out. And he tells the office he is not going to take this lying down, he and Dwight, they are going to go confront the CFO, and they're going to save the branch. How? What do they think they're going to do? But I do have an old tech alert, old tech track at 12 minutes, 50 seconds, Dwight says, hey, he's, you know, David Wallace isn't in the office, don't worry, I have his home address. And he goes to his flip phone, Jenna, do you see how he has to toggle to find the addresses?
鲍勃·万斯买下了库房，迈克尔开始真正情绪崩溃。他告诉办公室他不会就此罢休，他和德怀特，他们要去找首席财务官对质，他们要拯救分公司。怎么去？他们觉得自己能做什么？不过我在12分50秒处有一个“旧科技提醒”、旧科技彩蛋，德怀特说：“嘿，他，你知道的，大卫·华莱士不在办公室，别担心，我有他的家庭住址。”然后他翻出他的翻盖手机，珍娜，你看到他是怎么按键查找地址的吗？
Do you remember that? Yes. Yeah, and then he says, don't worry, he's on my Christmas card list. I loved this so much, Jenna, I love to think about what is Dwight's Christmas card? What is he sending out? It must be a picture of the beat farm, I feel like it's in some way also a piece of advertising. Maybe it's Moe's holding up a bunch of beats. I have a fan catch from Nico Martin, when Michael and Dwight are driving to David Wallace's
你还记得吗？记得。是的，然后他说：“别担心，他在我的圣诞贺卡名单上。”我太喜欢这个了，珍娜，我喜欢去想，德怀特的圣诞贺卡是什么样的？他会寄出什么？那一定是一张甜菜农场的照片，我觉得它在某种程度上也是一件广告。也许是莫斯举着一大把甜菜。我有一个来自尼科·马丁的粉丝发现，当迈克尔和德怀特开车去大卫·华莱士
house, the temperature in the car says it's 80 degrees outside. Why are Michael and Dwight wearing trench coats? Well, Nico, that's because we shot this episode in August, but it aired on November 9th. And we always tried to match the season in which the episode would air. So that is also why you're going to see pumpkins outside at David Wallace's house. We placed them there, even though it was August, to make it seem like it was fall. Yeah. We placed them there and hoped they wouldn't explode from the heat.
家时，车上的温度显示外面是80华氏度。为什么迈克尔和德怀特穿着风衣？嗯，尼科，那是因为我们在八月拍摄了这一集，但它是在11月9日播出的。我们总是尽量与剧集播出的季节保持一致。所以这也是为什么你在大卫·华莱士家外面会看到南瓜的原因。我们在那里摆放了南瓜，尽管当时是八月，为的是让它看起来像秋天。是的。我们把它们摆在那儿，祈祷它们不会被高温烤得炸开。
Well, let's talk a little bit about the CFO's house, because we got a lot of questions about it. It's a very nice house. We filmed there. I did a few episodes there, and it's a really beautiful home. Well, I'm rubbing off on you. I know. Sharlene Guevara asked, was that someone's actual house or was it random?
好吧，我们来聊聊这位首席财务官的房子，因为我们收到了很多关于它的问题。这是一栋非常漂亮的房子。我们在那儿拍过。我在那儿拍过好几集，那真的是一个美丽的家。好吧，我被你同化了。我知道。夏琳·格瓦拉问，那是某人的真房子还是随便找的？
And Dixie Hydrick said whose home was used as David Wallace's house and where was it located? Well, of course, I went to Kentopedia and he told me that David Wallace's house is located on Lomita Drive in Pasadena, California. It's a beautiful neighborhood. Oh, it's a beautiful neighborhood. It was three houses away from the house used on the TV show Benson. That's just a little bit of trivia for it.
迪克西·海德里克问，谁的家被用作大卫·华莱士的房子，它位于哪里？好吧，当然，我去了“肯托百科”，他告诉我大卫·华莱士的房子位于加利福尼亚州帕萨迪纳的洛米塔大道。那是一个美丽的社区。哦，它是一个美丽的社区。它离电视剧《本森》里使用的那栋房子只有三个街区的距离。这只是其中的一个小花絮。
So just a little bit more about this house, Jennifer Hodge and Whitney Grasik wrote in and said, at 14 minutes, 13 seconds, why does David Wallace have an H monogrammed welcome mat? Shouldn't it be a W? And Anna Worthington said, are they at the wrong house? Is that part of the joke? Did Dwight and Michael go to the wrong house and that's why there's an H instead of a W? Well Kent told me that it was the doormat of the people who owned the house and no one
所以关于这栋房子还有更多要说的，珍妮弗·霍奇和惠特尼·格拉西克写信来问，在14分13秒处，为什么大卫·华莱士有一个印着字母H的花体字欢迎门垫？难道不应该是W吗？安娜·沃辛顿问，他们是走错房子了吗？那是笑话的一部分吗？德怀特和迈克尔是不是走错了房子，所以才有一个H而不是W？好吧，肯告诉我，那是房子主人的门垫，直到他们进入剪辑室后才有人
noticed the mistake until after they were in the editing room. And you'll see in the future, this is David Wallace's house. They just forgot to replace the welcome mat. The welcome mat and also the golden retriever that's in the backyard. Oh, no, that's a whole story. That golden retriever was placed there. I'll get to it. Okay.
注意到这个错误。你会看到在未来，这就是大卫·华莱士的房子。他们只是忘了换掉欢迎门垫。欢迎门垫，还有后院的那只金毛寻回犬。哦，不，那可是一整段故事。那只金毛寻回犬是被放在那里的。我会讲到它的。好吧。
Well, I am intrigued, Jenna. So wrong doormat, but real dog will get to it. Maybe we should take a little break right now and when we come back, guys, we have a really fun guest. Yeah. All right. We'll see you in a second. All right, guys, we are back and we are in Stamford and Jan has called Jim and Josh into
好吧，我很感兴趣，珍娜。所以门垫错了，但狗是真的，我们会讲到它的。也许我们现在应该休息一下，等我们回来时，伙计们，我们有一位非常有趣的嘉宾。好的。好吧，一会儿见。好吧，伙计们，我们回来了，我们在斯坦福，简把吉姆和乔什叫进了
Josh's office and she announces that Josh will be heading up what is now called Dunder Mifflin Northeast. Jim will be his number two. This is exciting news. Jim is excited until Josh says, Jan, I have actually accepted an offer from Staples. Yeah. And he's going to take it. Senior management position at Staples.
乔什的办公室，她宣布乔什将负责现在被称为“邓德·米夫林东北部”的业务。吉姆将是他的二把手。这是一个令人兴奋的消息。吉姆很兴奋，直到乔什说：“简，其实我接受了史泰博公司的邀约。”是的。而且他打算去。那是史泰博公司的高级管理职位。
Jan is ticked off. She's like, you leveraged this new position to get the Staples job when we orchestrated this whole merger just so we could keep you. Yeah. So guys, this is it. This is the last time we see Josh Porter. This character has been with us for three seasons. He first came up in the pilot.
简气炸了。她说：“当我们为了留住你而精心策划了这次合并时，你却利用这个新职位去拿下了史泰博的工作。”所以，伙计们，就是这样。这是我们最后一次看到乔什·波特。这个角色已经陪伴我们三季了。他最初出现在试播集中。
We don't see him, but he's mentioned in a scene where Jan and Michael are talking about downsizing. We finally meet him on Valentine's Day and now he's leaving. And guys, Josh Porter, we've talked about this before, was played by Charles Eston. He appeared in eight episodes of the show. He did a weird pilot with Rainwilson. Yes. We never got to work with him, but he's an awesome guy and to commemorate his time on
我们没有看到他，但在简和迈克尔谈论精简人员的一个场景中提到了他。我们最终在情人节那天见到了他，现在他要离开了。伙计们，乔什·波特，我们之前讨论过，由查尔斯·埃斯顿饰演。他在这部剧中出现了八集。他跟雷恩·威尔逊拍过一个奇怪的试播集。是的。我们从没能和他一起工作，但他是个超级棒的人，为了纪念他在
the show, we reached out to him and we got to chat with him a little bit. All right. We're so excited to have him here. Let's play the interview. Hey, it's Chip. Hey, Chip. Ain't no party like a Scranton party. Because a Scranton party, don't stop.
剧中的时光，我们联系了他，并且和他聊了聊。好吧。我们非常高兴能邀请到他。让我们播放这段采访。嘿，我是奇普。嘿，奇普。斯克兰顿的派对永不停歇。因为斯克兰顿的派对，从不停止。
It's so great to see you. Thank you so much. Are you kidding me? It is so great to see you guys. You know how it is. You do a show with somebody and then there's just, you don't overlap again. And I'm in Nashville now, so I haven't been able to see you guys ever since then. And all I can say quickly is you could not have been kinder.
很高兴见到你。非常感谢。你在开玩笑吗？很高兴见到你们。你知道是怎么回事。你和某人合作过一部剧，然后就是，你们再也没有重合过。我现在在纳什维尔，所以从那以后我再也没能见到你们。我能简要说的一点是，你们不可能会更善良了。
Both of you were sincerely the only two nice people there. We know. Yeah. It's unfortunate. A bunch of jerks and then us. Everybody was nice, but you two were remarkably so considering we had no scenes at all together. You were very, very kind and I appreciated it. We were so excited to have you guys and we, you know, Jen and I were talking about this
你们两个真心实意地是那里仅有的两个好人。我们知道。是的。真遗憾。一堆混蛋，然后是我们。每个人都很好，但考虑到我们根本没有对手戏，你们两个格外地好，我很感激。我们很高兴能邀请到你们，而且我们，你知道的，珍妮和我一直在讨论这个
that we had major FOMO because it seemed like all these great stories were coming out of the Stamford branch and funny inside jokes and we were like, dang it, we want to go to Stamford. Well, picture it from the other direction where you're the guy that gets to go be on the office, but you don't get to go in the office. You're in another branch somewhere and you don't get to, you don't get to be with everybody, but you do get to be with, with Jim and he was awesome. John was fantastic.
我们有着极大的“错失恐惧症”（FOMO），因为似乎所有这些棒极了的故事都出自斯坦福分公司，还有有趣的内部笑话，我们就想：“该死，我们也想去斯坦福。”好吧，从另一个角度想象一下，你是那个得以去参演《办公室》，但你却没能真正走进办公室的人。你在某个分公司里，你没能去，你没能和大家在一起，但你确实能和吉姆在一起，他太棒了。约翰棒极了。
And you got to wear fancy biker shorts. Those were mine. I just showed up to work in those and no, yeah, I played the good boss. Well, you know, we've been trying to get ahold of you. Jenna was trying to slide into your DMs, but she must have jammed some other strangers. So you are not Chip Eston from Germany. No, I'm not. No, Charles underscore Eston and I have so many famous leading ladies from classic sitcoms
而且你还得穿时髦的骑行短裤。那是我的。我穿着它去上班，不，对，我扮演了一个好老板。好吧，你知道的，我们一直试图联系你。珍妮试图私信你，但她肯定塞给其他陌生人了。所以你不是来自德国的奇普·埃斯顿。不，我不是。不，Charles下划线Eston，有太多来自经典情景喜剧的著名女主角
trying to talk to me on Instagram that I have to. Yeah, it's so many. I know. Okay. So we usually ask people on the show their origin story about how they came to be on the office. Like what was their audition process? And we would love to hear yours.
试图在Instagram上和我聊天，以至于我不得不。是的，太多了。我知道。好吧。所以我们通常会问节目中的嘉宾他们的起源故事，也就是他们是如何来到《办公室》的。比如他们的试镜过程是怎样的？我们很想听听你的。
First of all, I was a British office fan, like so many from the very beginning. So I recall very, very well watching it, loving it all. And then I heard they were trying into the United States and like a lot of people went, Oh, wow. Okay. Good luck. But then I had known, then I heard about Steve and rain that they had been cast. And I was like, hmm, that's, that's a heck of a good start.
首先，我和许多人一样，从一开始就是英国版《办公室》的粉丝。所以我非常非常清楚地记得观看它，喜爱它的全部。然后我听说他们正试图将其引入美国，就像很多人一样，心想：“哦，哇。好吧。祝你好运。”但后来我认识了，然后我听说斯蒂夫和雷恩被选中了，我就想：“嗯，这，这算是一个相当不错的开始。”
They might have a shot at this. Now Steve, I don't know how I knew. We just knew each other from being in LA for a while, I think improv circles, maybe something like that. I don't think we'd ever work together, but he's somebody I'd see at the mall in Sherman Oaks. Hey, man. You go ahead.
他们说不定真能成。至于斯蒂夫，我不知道我是怎么知道的。我想我们只是因为在洛杉矶待了一段时间而认识彼此，大概是在即兴表演圈子里，或者类似的地方。我想我们从未一起工作过，但他是我在谢尔曼奥克斯的商场里会看到的人。“嘿，老兄。你忙你的。”
I love that you're seeing at the mall. That tracks. That tracks for Steve. That tracks. Steve, Steve used to like talk to Jenna and I about like really good buys that he found over the weekend. Well, he was working at Brookstone at the time. No, I'm kidding.
我喜欢你在商场里看到他。这很符合常理。这很符合斯蒂夫的风格。这很符合。斯蒂夫，斯蒂夫过去常常和珍妮和我谈论他在周末发现的一些非常棒的划算商品。好吧，他当时在Brookstone工作。不，我开玩笑呢。
He wasn't. I was going to be shocked. I was like, this is a piece of trivia. I didn't know. He was trying to sell me a massage chair. No, he never, as far as I know, he never worked there. Anyway, I would see him, but the way I knew rain is the interesting part that got me to the show.
他才没有。我当时会惊掉下巴的。我心想：这是一个我不知道的花絮。他当时正试图向我推销一把按摩椅。不，据我所知，他从来没在那儿工作过。不管怎样，我会看到他，但我是怎么认识雷恩的，这才是让我加入这部剧的有趣部分。
Rain and I, I'm going to say six or seven years. It's all a blur before that had been in an audition at NBC, you know, right across from the main place in Burbank was that little casting hut across the street there by the park. And we were reading for this thing called the expendables and the expendables were androids that solved crimes. These two guys, that's why they were expendable because who cares if they get, you know, you can't beat them.
雷恩和我，我要说是在那之前的六七年。在此之前的一切都有些模糊，当时我们在伯班克的NBC参加过一次试镜，就在主楼对面，公园旁边那个小小的选角小屋里。我们在为一部名为《敢死队》（The Expendables）的作品试读，那些敢死队是打击犯罪的安卓机器人。这两个家伙，这就是为什么他们是“敢死队”，因为谁在乎他们会不会，你知道的，你打不倒他们。
You can't defeat them. Chip, Chip, I did read about this. I read about this and I got so tickled. So go on, go on. So I remember it was pure chance because they literally said you with you, you read with you because it was, it's two guys. And so they, they paired us up and somehow just kismet rain and I got chosen to be together. And I remember forget we went outside and we had the script was, there was some things
你无法击败他们。奇普，奇普，我确实读到过这个。我读到过这个，然后我笑得不行。所以继续，继续。所以我记得那纯粹是偶然，因为他们字面意思上说：“你和，你，你和这个人搭词读，”因为这是，这是两个人的剧本。所以他们把我们配对在一起，不知怎么的，天意弄人，雷恩和我被选中分在了一起。我记得忘不了我们走到外面，剧本上，有一些台词
to say, but we went outside and said, let's just have fun with this. And by the time we came back in, first of all, I had fallen in love with the guy that is rain Wilson instantly. We just clicked like that. I was like, what an incredible guy with a mind. So we went in there and basically improvised on top of the script and ended up getting the job and then we all had a table read it NBC, right across the street in the big building. I'll never forget.
要说，但我们走到外面说：“咱们就拿这个找点乐子吧。”等我们走回来的时候，首先，我立刻就爱上了雷恩·威尔逊这个人。我们一下子就对上眼了。我心想：这是个多么不可思议、极具头脑的家伙啊。所以我们走进去，基本上在剧本的基础上进行了即兴发挥，最后得到了这份工作，然后我们所有人都在伯班克大楼街对面的NBC进行了一次剧本围读。我永远不会忘记。
There's this long conference table and we're all just reading the script and we're still messing around. We're still just being these two androids and just looking at you vaguely like, and so somehow we made it funny enough that they, they ended up shooting a pilot of it and that's where I really got to hang with them the most. So in any event, we shoot that, we have a ball, it does not get picked up. Shocker, shocker, shocker. So I get to the audition and it's going well.
那里有一张长长的会议桌，我们所有人都在读剧本，我们还在瞎胡闹。我们依然只是在扮演这两个安卓机器人，茫然地看着对方，发出……的声音，所以不知怎么的，我们把它演得足够搞笑，以至于他们最终拍摄了它的试播集，这也是我真正有机会和他们混得最熟的地方。无论如何，我们拍了那个，我们玩得很开心，它没有被续订。意料之中，意料之中，意料之中。所以我去试镜，进展得很顺利。
I'm doing well enough, I guess, but I think the separating factor was one of them says, so I hear your, I think it was my, I hear your, you, your friends with rain. And I was like, yes, I am. And I said, did rain ever tell you how we met? And they're like, no, I bet he didn't and I said, we met playing naked androids on a detective show and they were both like, they're like, and I said, and on top of that, if you give me this job, I show up day one with a DVD of that pilot, I'm not even to my car.
我想我表现得足够好，但我认为分水岭在于其中一个人说：“所以我听说你的，我想是我的，我听说你和雷恩是朋友。”我说是的，我是。我说雷恩有没有告诉过你我们是怎么认识的？他们说没有，我敢打赌他没有，我说我们是在一部侦探剧里扮演裸体安卓机器人时认识的，他们俩都露出了……的表情，我说除此之外，如果你把这份工作给我，我第一天上班就会带着那个试播集的DVD，甚至不用走到车里。
And I'm like, that's the fastest I ever got a job. So I had, it had nothing to do with my abilities or acting otherwise. It was purely that I had, I had this own rain. And so that's, that's my origin story and it's kind of special to me because it's who could imagine. By that point, I was already a fan. It was, it was like being on, it was like winning a radio contest to be on a show that I already loved.
我就想：这是我得到过最快的工作。所以这与我的能力或演技毫无关系。纯粹是因为我拥有这个雷恩。所以，这就是我的起源故事，它对我有种特殊意义，因为谁能想象得到呢。到那个时候，我已经是个粉丝了。这就好像在，这就好像赢得了一场电台比赛，得以参演一部我本就深爱的剧集。
I was very uncool about it because I was just so happy to be there, but you guys were all very cool about it. So Chip, after you got the job and you started working on the show, we said like, it looked like you guys were having so much fun. What was it like to get to do these scenes with like Ed Helms and Steve Carell and Rashida Jones? Like, do you have any, any episodes in particular that you have fun memories of? There is the one episode where Josh is very mad at Jim because Jim is playing Call of
我对这件事表现得很不酷，因为我只是太高兴能身处其中了，但你们所有人都表现得很酷。所以奇普，在你得到这份工作并开始参演这部剧之后，我们说过，看起来你们玩得太开心了。和埃德·海尔姆斯、斯蒂夫·卡瑞尔以及拉什达·琼斯这样的人一起演这些戏是什么感觉？比如，你有没有哪几集特别让你有美好回忆的？就是有一集，乔什对吉姆非常生气，因为吉姆在玩《使命召唤》
Duty and uses a sniper rifle and he's just started screaming at him. And, and of course, Ed, it was amazing and that scene goes off. And so what I didn't realize is that everybody was playing that game for real on the breaks on the set. Did you guys have that same thing in yours? I believe, right? Yeah. The computers were actually hooked up and everybody was playing Call of Duty.
并且用了一把狙击步枪，然后他就开始冲吉姆大喊大叫。而且，当然，埃德，这太棒了，那个场景就这样爆发了。所以，我当时没有意识到的是，大家在片场的休息时间里都在玩那个游戏。你们的剧组也有同样的情况吗？我想是的，对吧？是的。电脑实际上是连着网的，每个人都在玩《使命召唤》。
So they just wrote it into the show. Everybody, I had to, I hadn't played that much. I was like, now what rifle would they use? And they explained everything to me and then we went and we, we did it and it was so much fun. Yeah. Our writers and editors were really into that. We didn't get to do that on set.
所以他们就把这个写进了剧里。每个人，我不得不，我以前没玩过那么多。我心想：“现在他们会用什么步枪呢？”他们向我解释了一切，然后我们去了，我们拍了，太好玩了。是的。我们的编剧和剪辑师真的很迷那个。我们在片场没能玩那个。
We were always a little bummed, but they were playing it all the time. And on the DVD commentary, they did mention that John mentioned that's like one of the hardest times he had to work not to laugh was in that scene with you and Ed. And you guys were just going off on him about Call of Duty. That's the thing is you're in this business so long and you're in things that are pretty good. You're in things that are not good at all. And you're always, this funny thing after the show is I remember people would walk up
我们总是觉得有点遗憾，但他们一直在玩。而且在DVD花絮评论中，他们确实提到过，约翰说过那是他极力克制自己不笑的最艰难的时刻之一，就在那场你和埃德的戏里。你们俩当时就在冲他发飙，说的全是关于《使命召唤》的事。事情就是这样，你在这一行待了这么久，你参演过挺不错的作品。你也参演过一点都不好的作品。演完之后总有一件很有趣的事，我记得人们会走过来
to me and go, I saw you on the office. You're very funny. And I knew that what it really was, is I, I didn't say that many. I wasn't the funny part of, I was more of the situation than the comedy, but I did get some great, very, very funny lines. And here I was just in a room with Ed and John and Rashida and, and trying not to laugh or, or just watching Michael Scott when he says, I love inside jokes, like to be a part of one someday.
对我说：“我在《办公室》里看到过你。你非常搞笑。”而我知道真实情况其实是，我，我台词没那么多。我不是喜剧的笑点所在，我更多的是处境而非喜剧，但我确实有一些非常、非常搞笑的台词。当时我就在一个房间里，和埃德、约翰还有拉什达在一起，努力不笑出来，或者只是看着迈克尔·斯科特说：“我喜欢内部笑话，希望有一天能成为其中一部分。”
That's just as good a line as anybody can write. And all I had to do was stand there and just do the thing where you don't laugh and you're kind of, you know, the cringe. And I couldn't believe I was, it was thrilling. Well, so what is it like for you now? Like the office has had this new life on Netflix and it's everywhere. Do you get stopped? Do you get recognized for being on the show?
这台词写得跟任何人写的一样好。而我所需要做的就是站在那里，摆出那种不笑的表情，你知道的，那种尴尬的窘态。我简直不敢相信自己能参与其中，太让人激动了。好吧，那么对现在的你来说，这是怎样的体验？比如《办公室》在Netflix上获得了全新的生命，到处都是。你会被人拦下吗？你会因为参演这部剧而被认出来吗？
What it mostly is on social media is that I was on other things since and like when I was on Nashville, I played a character called Deacon and I was, people would watch it. And it was a very dramatic, very sort of, he was, he was in AA and he was, he was trying not to drink anymore and he loved this woman. So it was always very dramatic, very heartfelt, played music, did all these things. So inevitably I would see a tweet that would say, just realized that Deacon from Nashville is Josh from Stanford. And then it always had that hashtag, mind blown.
这种情况主要发生在社交媒体上，因为我在那之后还演过其他作品，比如当我出演《纳什维尔》时，我扮演了一个叫迪肯的角色，人们会看这部剧。这是一部非常戏剧化、非常走心的剧，他当时在戒酒互助会（AA），他努力不再喝酒，并且深爱着这个女人。所以这总是非常戏剧化、发自内心，还要弹奏音乐，做所有这些事情。所以不可避免地，我会看到一条推特上面写着：“刚意识到《纳什维尔》里的迪肯就是斯坦福的乔什。”然后后面总是带着那个话题标签：脑洞大开。
So that's mostly where it happened. It used to be that the office was a little bit more niche like somebody go, I know you're from the office, but now it's, you're right, there's just a resurgence. It's just a second thing. The best evidence of that is my own kids when I was doing the show, they were in junior high elementary, maybe one of them was in high school. No, they weren't. They were in junior high.
所以这种情况主要就是这么发生的。以前《办公室》稍微小众一点，有人会说：“我知道你是《办公室》里的谁谁谁。”但现在，你是对的，它迎来了一波复苏。这已经是第二春了。最好的证据就是我自己的孩子，当我拍这部剧时，他们还在初中、小学，也许其中一个在高中。不，他们不在。他们在初中。
So they didn't know what the office was really. They didn't watch television at all. But now, it's going back, how many years has it been at this resurgence? Three years? More? Whatever it is. Oh gosh. It feels like in the last three or four years.
所以他们其实并不知道《办公室》是什么。他们根本不看电视。但现在，回顾过去，这波复苏已经持续多少年了？三年？更多？不管怎样。哦天哪。感觉就像在过去的三四年里。
Yeah. The last three years, I think. It was always on in our house. I think I told Angela it was on in the summer more than the air conditioning. It was just, and they fell in love with it. They knew it so well. So that was maybe the first time when it was really cool that they, they, they, they were cool.
是的。过去的三年，我想是的。它一直在我们家里播放。我想我告诉过安吉拉，夏天它播出的频率比空调开得还要高。它就是一直在放，他们也爱上了这部剧。他们对它太熟悉了。所以这也许是第一次真正酷炫的时刻，他们，他们表现得很酷。
Chill about it. Like, yeah, you're on it. But I could tell it meant a lot. And it means a lot to me. Aw. That is so cool. The other rabbit hole I fall down with you guys is the, um, uh, what do you call it? The bloopers.
对此很淡定。就像：“对，你演了。”但我能看出这意义重大。这对我也意义重大。哇。太酷了。我和你们一起陷入的另一个“兔子洞”是，呃，你们管它叫什么？花絮。
The bloopers on Netflix. If I start watching one, I'm there all the time. And I think that's because it's the best of remembering the parts of the show you love so much. But then getting to see how authentically funny it struck you guys. Like sometimes you'd be watching, you go, this is insane. They don't seem to think this is funny. I mean, I'm an actor and I would think that and then you'd come away and you would see
Netflix上的花絮。如果我开始看一个，我就会一直在那儿看。我想这是因为这是重温剧中那些你如此深爱部分的最棒方式。但随后又能看到它对你们产生了多么真实、好笑的冲击。有时看着看着你会想：“这太疯狂了。他们怎么会觉得这不好笑。”我的意思是，身为演员，我会那么想，然后你会回过头去看到
where everybody did break up at that line or where there would be lines that you just could not get out to save your life. And those always killed me. And also the scenes that never made it. I had a great scene with Malora, um, that didn't, that didn't make it in. We were at the convention and at the end of the night, all this stuff is going on. Um, I'm walking Jan and Josh are walking, uh, towards the elevators and basically Jan stops and invites Josh on up for the night.
每个人都在哪句台词上笑场了，或者有哪些台词是你绞尽脑汁也说不出口的。那些总是把我笑死。还有那些从未播出的场景。我和马洛拉有一场很棒的戏，呃，没有被剪进去。我们在参加年会，那天结束的时候，所有这些事情都在发生。嗯，我正走着，简和Josh正走向电梯，基本上简停了下来，邀请Josh上去过夜。
That's on the DVD set. She totally hits on you and you're like, nah, I'm good. Nah, I'm good. I'm good. I'm going to go to Staples. Exactly. I know you talked about how you were the good boss, but in this episode, at the end, you sort of serve up the ultimate betrayal and you leverage your job for a position at Staples.
那段在DVD套装里。她完全是在向你调情，而你说：“算了，我挺好的。算了，我挺好的。我挺好的。我要去史泰博了。”确实如此。我知道你谈到过你是如何成为一个好老板的，但在这一集中，在结尾，你某种程度上抛出了终极背叛，你利用你的工作去争取史泰博的一个职位。
What did you think when you read that? Were you disappointed at all and Josh or did you, were you like, I get it. I mean, who wants to work with this group of loonies? At that point, I was just more disappointed for Chip than I was disappointed at Josh because I knew that Ed and Rashida were, were moving on over and I knew it. I always knew that it wouldn't work to have the other boss there with him. I just saw something the other day, Janet, that, but I've done a lot of drama. There are moments that the moment where he admires your painting so much and he says,
你读到这里时是怎么想的？你对乔什有任何失望吗？还是说你会觉得，我理解？我的意思是，谁想和这群疯子一起工作？当时，我比起对乔什感到失望，更多的是为奇普感到失望，因为我知道埃德和拉什达要转过去加入他们了，我心里有数。我一直都知道让另一个老板和他在那里行不通。我前几天刚看到一个片段，珍妮，虽然我演过很多正剧。有些时刻，他非常崇拜你的画作，他说：
that's our office and you're just looking at him and you hug him. That's to me as emotional and as real and as heartbreaking as any drama anywhere. So that's another thing. I've always loved about it. And you guys. Oh yeah. For sure. I mean, Steve broke my heart many times on the show just with his sort of childlike innocence
“那是我们的办公室，”而你只是看着他，然后你拥抱了他。对我来说，那和任何地方的任何正剧一样充满情感、真实且让人心碎。所以这也是我一直以来深爱这部剧的原因。还有你们。哦，是的。当然。我的意思是，斯蒂夫在剧中凭借他那种孩子般的纯真
as Michael, even though he was a lot of times just a real like, I don't know, like idiot. Like he was also this very pure hearted person and complicated. Yeah. And I look now and I know how hard that is for writers. We've seen out things on different shows that go another season and another season. It's like, how do they keep it all together? Cause that's always the tension when you have the full, when you have the more honor people, what makes them funny is how out there they are.
饰演迈克尔，多次让我心碎，尽管他很多时候真的就像个，我不知道，就像个白痴。但他同时也是一个内心非常纯洁且复杂的人。是的。我现在回想起来，我知道这对编剧来说有多难。我们在不同的剧集中看到有些剧被续订了一季又一季。就好像，他们是怎么把这一切维系在一起的？因为当你拥有这群性格张扬的角色时，这总是张力的来源，让他们变得有趣的是他们有多么出格。
What makes them human is the grounding of that and giving up the other side. That tension between those two things, it's so hard to ride where you don't make them not funny anymore. Cause now they're just super human and kind and don't we love them or other times you just leave them like they don't have any arc at all. They're just that same person. They always were. The way that they did that over the seasons with you guys is just, it's, it's very unusual
and special. Well, your character of Josh had a great arc. I did. You thought I was the perfect guy. That is the other thing is that I always thought this is charismatic at all comes very easy to him. Um, and in the end, uh, he does that. I had one of the fun thing at a, um, when Ed was on my final episode, Josh is the reason
that branch is, is essentially going to be shutting down. So at that point, uh, he doesn't think he has a job anymore. He's just flipping out Andy is, um, so there's that, there's a scene in the kitchen they had and all the scene was, was Andy walks in there, he's pouring some coffee or something. And all of a sudden we get that first hint of that Andy Bernard anger that he later has to do it. And he just flips out and sort of destroys everything and stops. And that was the scene.
And I was real proud cause I said, what if Josh, the guy that's the cause of all it walked in right after that and just to say goodbye, my guess is that Andy is not strong enough or brave enough to do anything, but go, great. It was awesome. Great. And just, you know, he would have to cover his fury immediately and be sort of the worst that he was in that moment. And, and they said, yeah, let's try that.
So that was a lot of fun. He destroys that room and I walk in there and I go, listen, Andy, it's been great. And he's like, yeah, awesome. Good luck. Good luck. Everything like that. So that was very cool. That was your pitch.
I love that. I love that. You know, Chip, we talk about this a lot that we had this creative collaboration that we could in the moment pitch something to the writer on set and we were heard. And that is so rare, truly. And we were so lucky to have that relationship with our writers. And I love that. We didn't know that.
We didn't know that was your pitch. That's so cool. And also furthers the Andy character because Andy was always just white knuckling his anger, you know, and suppressing it until eventually, you know, he's going to punch the wall. But you love seeing him try to contain that such an Andy thing too. So that's kind of cool that I, that I get to see that we get to see. And also the other thing, how cool is it when you have a little idea, a little pitch and you're surrounded by people that are going to make your pitch amazing.
I've been in other places where you make a pitch and they try it and it just doesn't get sold the way that you had it in your head, but that got sold out and beyond anything I could imagine what he'd do with it. So that totally did. And it absolutely just crystallize who Andy was, you know, just all of that moment says who he is. That is fantastic. I love that story.
Oh, Chip, thank you so much. Thank you for coming on here and sharing about your time on the office. We are so glad that we got ahold of you. Thank you guys. Where can we find you? Tell us where you are on Instagram. I'm at Charles underscore eston. I'm also Charles eston on Twitter and Facebook.
Good. And you're also you're on a show right now called Outer Banks on Netflix. Yeah, we were number one on Netflix. Wow. Including the little show called The Office for a quick minute there. Yeah. It's something else. It's really kind of amazing.
We shot it last summer. It's sort of a young adult thrilling adventure. Has this amazing life all its own. As I said, we knocked Tiger King out of first place. Tiger King. That's something. That says something. And then I have one more thing to share with everyone.
You do a weekly Saturday Facebook live stream and it's called Quarantine live stream. Is that right? Yeah. Because of the show Nashville, I have to play out of music on that. So that's why I'm still here in Nashville. I get to do very cool things. I play at the Grand Ole Opry or the Bluebird or the Ryman and tour around and make music. So I'm on Spotify too.
But in any event, so I just play a couple songs on the show on the Quarantine live stream. And then I do another thing where I do a duet with somebody. I send them video of me singing, they listen and sing along and we put them together in a video. So there's always a duet. And then I do interviews as well. Just like you're doing right here. Last week was Old Dominion.
The band Old Dominion I interviewed. Well Chip, thank you so much. It was such a delight. Thank you guys very much for having me. I love that you're doing this. Everybody loves that you're doing this. This thing is on fire. This podcast.
Because what would they want more than discuss these things with you guys? So well done and hopefully I get to see you down the road in some other situation. But thanks for having me. Thanks Chip. We love you. Love you. Love you too. Bye guys.
Bye. All right. So that was amazing. Thank you so much Chip. It was that was really cool. I'm glad we were able to commemorate his time on the show. And to all of you other Chips slash Charles is out there that Jenna slid into your DMs. We apologize.
That's right. Okay Jenna, where are we? So Dwight and Michael are still outside of David Wallace's house and they've decided that they're going to practice. They're going to role play what Michael is going to say when he sees David walking up, right? Yeah, they got to be prepared. Yes.
So I traded some messages with Mike Scherr and he told me that there was an element of the scene that was improvised and it made everyone laugh so hard that they were able to keep it in but they had to cut at this one moment because right after that moment, like one second after that moment, everyone started breaking. So during this scene when they're role playing Dwight is pretending to be David Wallace and he's doing a good job. He's making good arguments. So Michael gets frustrated and he has this line where he says something like, just go
back and start over and be more intimidated by me. Okay, that's where it was supposed to end. That was the scripted ending of the scene. But when they shot it, Rain walks back in and Steve says, Mr. Wallace, Rain goes, ugh, kind of like he's terrified. That was the moment. Mike said it was amazing and we literally couldn't go one frame later because they both started laughing hysterically.
Yes, I love that because Steve is Michael is like, be more scared of me and don't touch me. Yeah. It was so good. It was so good. All right, so now, lady, do you want me to tell you about this dog? Yes, I want you to tell me about the dog because I saw the doormat and I was like, oh yeah, they just forgot.
They forgot. And then I saw the dog and I was like, well, then that's, that's those people's dog, right? No, it's crazy. All right. So there's the scene where Dwight is sifting through the garbage. And by the way, this scene of him looking through the garbage, this was another one of those scenes that had been cut for the regular network airing of this episode. We got a ton of questions about this scene.
Jocelyn Beacher wrote in and said, at 19 minutes at David Wallace's house, there's a dog in the yard. Did they specifically cast for a dog or did that dog belong to the people who own the house? All right, the dog in the backyard was something that they added. And they added it because they thought that there might be more of a feeling of jeopardy involved. If there was like this guard dog or this watch dog standing behind Dwight as he sifted through
the garbage. That was the friendliest looking dog ever. That dog was wagging its tail. It looked like it just wanted to play fetch. That dog made me want to get another dog and we already have two dogs and two cats. I mean. I know. Kent told me they hired a dog trainer.
They hired this dog and he was so sweet. He just wanted to play. He just wanted to like lick your hand that he was like in no way intimidating just like you said. Yeah. But they stuck with it. They stuck with it. They were like, this dog is going to be in the shot.
We paid for this dog. Well, the dog looks so friendly to me. I just thought the owner's dog got out in the back of the shot and they left it in. That's what it looked like. Totally. All right. Well, listen. Back in Scranton.
Phyllis is bummed out. She's trying to organize a group lunch. Yeah. Yeah. And of course, you know, she goes to the fun stopper Angela Martin and they're throwing out some things DJs, which by the way, DJs is a hoagie shop. And then there's Cajino's Italian family cuisine, right? And Angela's like, I don't want to drive to Dunmore.
Jenna, I looked it up. Scranton to Dunmore. Nine minutes. Oh. You don't want to drive nine minutes. Nine minutes. And then Kevin's like, what about Cooper's? And she's like, no seafood.
And I want you to know, Brian and I have been to Cooper's when we went to Scranton and they gave us like a little hat that looks like lobster, what do you call them? Claws. Yeah. They gave us each hat. I have photos of Brian and I like drinking beers with these lobster claw hats on. It was really fun. But yeah, Angela Martin's very against seafood and then I can't even believe Kevin suggests
Hooters to her. Are you kidding me? I know. In the middle of all this, Phyllis just walks away. She's like, never mind. Yeah. You guys are the worst. At the same time, Creed is walking around, he's dealing with this by selling everything
in the office. He's selling the equipment, the fax machine, his personal computer. And I think if you look on the wall behind him, the dust buster off the wall, it's gone. I have a hair catch for Creed. I think this episode debuts a new hairstyle for Creed. It's poofy. It's like they blow dried it straight up in the air and then like used a rolling brush. I want you to look at his hair.
It is so poofy. It made me laugh. Lady, I noticed the same thing. I had the same note. Creed hair? Yeah. I wrote down what's up with Creed's hair. Did they use the rolling brush on him?
Like what's happening? We're going to have to track it because I want to see if that continues in future episodes, this new way of doing Creed's hair. The poofy. It's so poofy. Yes. By the way, that whole storyline of Creed selling stuff, that was the other thing that was cut out originally and was added back for the extended cut.
So the three main things were the Meredith storyline, this Creed storyline and Dwight going through the trash. Got it with the friendly dog. Yes, with the friendly dog. All right. So now Jan enters, she's looking for Michael because things have changed. Josh Porter threw them for a loop. They've had to reorganize restructure and she wants to let them know that now Scranton
is staying and Stanford is going to be merging into Scranton, right? Yes. Michael, Michael has been ignoring phone calls and a lady, we have some major philisass. What's the philisass? Well, it is at 20 minutes, 40 seconds. She looks at Jan and she goes, we know the branch is closing and she gives Jan the snarkiest look. It's so amazing.
It cracked me up and I was looking online for like sassy office moments. I just wanted to see if this had been clocked. Okay. On May 16th, 2020, which is just a few days ago from this recording, right? Yes. There is a new YouTube video collage that someone made called sassiest moments on YouTube, sassiest moments from the office. I think they have been listening to the podcast because all of a sudden, there's the sassiest
moments collage on YouTube. Angela, you 100% started sass. You started it early with Angela sass. If anyone is out there using sass or sassing or referring to something as sass, I want everyone to know that you started it 100%. You should have trademarked it. Well, I just couldn't believe there's now, just now, like just this week, there's a YouTube collage called sassiest moments of the office.
Anyway, there's major fill of sass here. So yes, Jan tells everyone the Scranton branch is safe for now. There's a lot of mixed emotions. Some people are really happy. Some people are sad. Kevin and Angela have a huge hug. Oh, lady, we got a fan question about that from Phoebe Tomak. When Kevin hugs Angela and picks her up, it looks like Angela got crushed a little bit
and she wants to know if you got hurt. No, I did not get hurt. That was just, I think, Brian having a little bit of fun because he is such a big guy and he can pick me up really easily. When would our characters ever hug or be this happy together? So that was just something he added. It wasn't in the script and he and I cracked up. I think you see me, like, I think I'm genuinely laughing because it made us laugh.
So also in the scene, Angela, Pam asks Jan, is anyone coming back to Scranton? We know who she's thinking about. And over in Stamford, Andy is asking Jim if he's going to go back to Scranton. And he sort of says he doesn't know yet. He's not sure. He's thinking about it. And then Ryan in the kitchen is like, I'm a little nervous about Jim coming back. I just hope it's not weird.
Pam, of course, totally internalizes this. Like, oh, my God, he knows, he knows. And he's like, I took his job. I sit at his desk. It's more about, it's all about him, right? Yeah. And so Pam is kind of relieved in that moment. Next Ryan's going to have his talking head where he knows he'll be saying at Scranton.
Here's the moment, 23 minutes, six seconds from here on out, all of the talking heads are facing back into the office. Oh, lady, this is your proudest podcast deep dive moment, maybe. I think it is. I think this ranks right up there with your alpha womb deep dive. Oh, I did enjoy alpha womb. Yes, you did. Yes, you did.
Then over in Stanford, Karen is saying, you know, she would move to Scranton if they offered it to her. Jim gives this poor woman so many mixed messages, OK? Yeah. Add some beef with Jim because he's like, why would you do that? Just go to New York. I mean, you're 45 minutes from New York. Why would you go to Scranton, right?
And then he pivots back the other way at the end and tells her to take the job. I feel bad. I feel bad for her. I feel like these mixed messages are going to play out through the whole Jim-Karen relationship, actually. Yeah. Jim is very wishy-washy with her, in my opinion. In this scene at 23 minutes, 17 seconds, I have a Lee catch.
Your husband, Lee? My husband, Lee. We were watching this. You're like, what other Lee am I talking about? Like, yes, my husband, Lee. OK. Well, Lee, we watched this episode together and he said, oh, my gosh, look at the sign behind Karen's head during this conversation about whether or not she should move to Scranton.
Do you know what it says? No. It says, window of opportunity. An obstacle to one is an opportunity to another. Whoa. I just thought we thought this was interesting because I was showing him all the talking heads and he was like, oh, look at what's behind Karen. It's a window of opportunity.
Layers, layers. Well, back in Scranton, Meredith is congratulating Creed on his business venture. He's made $1,200. And finally, Gary Trendle calls. He calls Meredith. Do you know why? He used to work at the Scranton branch and he says, I heard the branch was closing. Do you still want to make good on our agreement?
Meredith found her guy. She did make a sex pact with someone. She almost confesses the branch isn't closing and then she's like, can you meet me at my place in 20 minutes? We had a fan question from Bailey Aspenson at 24 minutes, 30 seconds when Meredith is talking on the phone. Who is she talking to? Do you know?
Of course I don't know. Kent Sabornak. Finally. Kent. Kentopedia. Finally, Kent. Kent Sabornak played the voice of Gary Trendle. He was going to be my first guest.
Yes. Yes. So Dwight and Michael are in the car and they're reminiscing now about their favorite memories of Dunder Mifflin because they've ignored phone calls, you know, and they don't know that their jobs are safe. And Dwight says to Michael, what's your favorite memory? You know? All of it, all of it.
And then Dwight goes, even the part where the branch was closed and he's like, Dwight, was that part scripted when Rain said it was? Yes. Okay. That scene in the car is almost word for word scripted. All right. I didn't know if that was like Rain tagging the end of the scene. So I love that.
It's so funny, Angela, because the reason I know that is because I had the same thought when I watched it and I checked. I wanted to know, is that scripted? Well, here's the thing we often could add a line at the end of a scene. That's the easiest place to improvise because it doesn't really mess up the context of the scene. So whenever I see these little throwaways at the end, especially by Steve and Rain, I always wonder.
太搞笑了，安吉拉，因为我知道这个是因为我在看的时候也有同感，我还去查证了。我想知道，那是剧本里写的吗？其实，我们经常会在场景结束时加一句台词。那是最好即兴发挥的地方，因为它不会真正打乱场景的上下文。所以每当我看到这些结尾处的小随性台词，尤其是史蒂夫和雷恩说的，我总是很好奇。
Yeah. Nope. That one was totally, totally scripted. Well, now we're back at Scranton and the gang is going out for shots. Creed is buying because Creed made some money today. Jenna, did you notice as Angela leaves what a big wave she gives to Roy? No, this is more, more of more of Angela and Roy. Oh my gosh.
对。没有。那段绝对、绝对是剧本里写好的。好吧，现在我们回到了斯克兰顿，大家要出去喝一杯。克里德请客，因为克里德今天赚了点钱。珍娜，你注意到了吗？当安吉拉离开时，她对罗伊挥了多么大的一下手啊？不，这更是……更多关于安吉拉和罗伊的互动。噢天哪。
It's almost awkward. It's almost awkward at 26 minutes, 35 seconds. She walks by and literally goes like this. You guys can't see me, but I'm going to do it for Jenna. Oh, that's a big wave. Yes. It's a really big wave. So she for sure is like, by handsome.
这简直有点尴尬。在26分35秒时，这简直太尴尬了。她走过去，字面意思上就是这样做的。大家虽然看不到我，但我现在要为珍娜表演一下。噢，那真是一个很大的挥手。是的。真的是一个非常大的挥手。所以她绝对是在说，再见帅哥。
Well, Pam now has her talking head facing into the office, I will say, and she is giddy. She's giddy. She's saying stuff like, oh, you know, it's good because finding another job is kind of a pain. And there are reasons to stay, but underneath all she is thinking is, Jim is coming back, Jim is coming back, Jim is coming back, Jim is coming back. That's everything, everything. You're so excited for her.
好吧，现在帕姆的单人访谈镜头面向着办公室了，我得说，她现在得意忘形了。她得意洋洋的。她说诸如，哦，你知道的，这挺好，因为再找一份工作挺麻烦的。而且留下来也有理由，但她内心深处想的全都是，吉姆要回来了，吉姆要回来了，吉姆要回来了，吉姆要回来了。这就是全部，一切。你太为她高兴了。
And then we go to Stamford and Jim tells Karen he thinks she should take a job in Scranton too. And Karen just lays it all out for the camera crew. She's just like, hey, I'm happy you said that. I don't think he's into me, but I'm kind of into him. So there's that. Wow. This is like someone who's sort of unapologetically into this guy.
然后我们转到斯坦福，吉姆告诉凯伦他认为她也应该接受一份在斯克兰顿的工作。凯伦直接向摄像团队全盘托出了。她就像是，嘿，我很高兴你这么说。我觉得他对没我那意思，但我对他有点意思。所以就是这样。哇。这就像是一个对这个男生毫不掩饰地有好感的人。
I dig it about her. I like it. Jim doesn't even tell her apparently about what went on with Pam. So she's walking into Scranton and she has no idea that he kissed the receptionist. She has no idea that there was this four year flirtation. She's just like, I like this guy. I'm going to go to Scranton and see what happens. I'm going to take it one step more and say, she has no idea that he said, I love you.
我很欣赏她这一点。我喜欢。吉姆显然甚至没有告诉她关于帕姆的事情。所以她走进斯克兰顿的时候，完全不知道他吻了前台。她完全不知道这里面有长达四年的暧昧。她只是觉得，我喜欢这个家伙。我要去斯克兰顿看看会发生什么。我要更进一步地说，她根本不知道他说过，我爱你。
Hello. I love you to the receptionist. We are being very team Karen Philippelli right now. We are because Jim, Jim is spiraling. Let's be honest. I mean, listen, I can justify Jim's choices and his behavior. He has a broken heart. He's confused.
你好。我爱前台。我们现在完全是凯伦·菲利佩利后援团了。我们确实是，因为吉姆，吉姆的状态正在失控。说实话。我是说，听吧，我可以为吉姆的选择和行为进行辩解。他心碎了。他很困惑。
He's crushed. We've all been wishy-washy. We've all, you know, we've all kind of done versions of this in our life and had versions of it done to us. All right, so moving on, Dwight and Michael are still outside David Wallace's house. He's never come home. It's dark. They're hungry, but Dwight won't let them leave.
他备受打击。我们都曾举棋不定过。我们都，你知道的，我们在生活中都做过类似的事情，也经历过别人对我们做类似的事情。好了，继续，德怀特和迈克尔仍然在大卫·华莱士的房子外面。他一直没回家。天黑了。他们很饿，但德怀特不让他们离开。
But finally he says, yes, we can go. And as they're leaving Dwight checks his phone, clearly gets a message that their jobs are safe and this is delightful. They're like, we did it. We did it. They start like bumping chess, yeah, but they literally are like, we did it. What did they do? And even at the end, I think Steve is Michael is like, wait, what did we do?
但最后他说，好吧，我们可以走了。就在他们离开的时候，德怀特查看了他的手机，显然收到了一条消息，说他们的工作保住了，这太令人高兴了。他们就像是，我们做到了。我们做到了。他们开始像那样碰胸庆祝，是的，但他们真的是在说，我们做到了。他们做了什么？甚至到了最后，我觉得史蒂夫饰演的迈克尔还在说，等等，我们做了什么？
Yeah, how did this happen? I'm so confused. But I love it. I love it too. They're so happy. And then the whole episode ends with Toby saying, well, I guess I won't go to Costa Rica. I'll just, it'll be there when I'm 65. Yeah, exactly.
对，这怎么发生的？我太困惑了。但我喜欢。我也很喜欢。他们太高兴了。然后整集节目在托比说“好吧，我想我不用去哥斯达黎加了。我只是，等我65岁的时候它还在那里吧”中结束。是的，完全是这样。
Oh, guys, there you have it. That's branch closing. That is branch closing. Guys, next week, we have a very special episode of Office Ladies. We are going to revisit our Casino Night episode with special guest Ken Qabis. Yes, the director is coming on to give us all of the behind the scenes stuff. This was such a big episode and so many of you wrote in that we thought, let's revisit it with the director.
噢，各位，就是这样。那是分公司关闭。那是分公司关闭。各位，下周我们有一期非常特别的《办公室淑女》节目。我们将带着特邀嘉宾肯·卡维斯重温我们的《赌场之夜》这一集。是的，导演要来给我们讲讲所有的幕后故事。这一集太重要了，你们有那么多人在来信中讨论，所以我们想，让我们和导演一起重温它。
Answer some of your questions and talk a little bit more about it. Thank you so much for calling in, Chip, and thank you guys for tuning in. We'll see you next week. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkin. Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubacow.
回答你们的一些问题，再多聊聊这一集。非常感谢你打电话进来，奇普，也谢谢大家收听。我们下周见。感谢收听《办公室淑女》。《办公室淑女》由Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的节目执行制片人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的制作人是卡西·杰金。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的助理制作人是艾因斯利·巴巴考。
Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code, OFFICE. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。想要收听无广告版本的《办公室淑女》，请访问StitcherPremium.com。如需免费试用一个月Stitcher Premium，请使用兑换码：OFFICE。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。